back here at home Republicans are hoping
to pick up a US Senate seat this fall in
West Virginia where President Trump won
easily in 2016 but the GOP primary there
might not produce the most electable
opponent against Democrat incumbent joe
Manchin Peter Doocy
has the story tonight from Charleston
West Virginia the race to replace one of
the most vulnerable Democrats in the
country has been upended by primary
candidate with a probation officer that
candidate with a criminal record is Don
Blankenship the former CEO the Massey
Energy Company is well known in West
Virginia for among other things a
conviction on a misdemeanor charge of
conspiring to violate federal mine
safety standards following an explosion
at the Upper Big Branch mine that killed
29 now he thinks the time locked up
gives them a leg up I was walking point
for the coal industry in West Virginia
and in fact for a West Virginia
conservative politics and it probably
doesn't surprise them that much that
Obama and his people would come after me
and they did Blankenship makes the May 8
primary a three-way contest with
congressman Evan Jenkins and the state's
Attorney General Patrick Morrissey the
winner faces incumbent Democratic
Senator Joe Manchin who declined to be
interviewed for this story in a State
President Trump won by 42 percentage
points in 2016 inspiring the governor
Jim Justice to jump ship from the
Democratic Party
now Morrissey the AG is trying to
discredit one of his opponents for his
past affiliation as a Democrat I think
Evan Jenkins is a liberal Jenkins the
congressman is using Morrissey's past
history in the Garden State against him
and the other candidate is a person who
ran for Congress in the year 2000 on a
theme that he was Jerzy through and
through but they're alike in that they
put a premium on portraying a proximity
to the president we work closely with
the White House and the agencies to roll
back some of those egregious those
burdensome regulations I'm the only
candidate who actually has an
established working relationship with
the president as for Blankenship he's
hyping his status as a political
newcomer he insists this campaign is not
an attempt to get even with Manchin
whose governor during the Upper Big
Branch disaster and later said
Blankenship had blood on his hands
senator Manchin needs to be defeated for
the sake of West Virginians not for
revenge the day after tomorrow President
Trump is coming to West Virginia for a
roundtable about jobs
attorney general Morrissey and
congressman Jenkins have both been
invited in their official capacities we
don't know if an endorsement is imminent
but Jenkins tells me any kind words from
the commander-in-chief would be a big
boost Brett produced in Charleston West
Virginia Peter thanks